Thank you. Surf shark VPN for sponsoring this video.
Are you planning on playing any other games on this channel?
I do play other games sometimes I'm currently working on it with a potato PC.
So I, um, it's given up on me a few times when I've tried to play other games,
but I do play the forest. I play, I, I play with my Dick on a Tuesday.
you and Jesus. you. Lasagna. Lasagna.
Lasagna.
I really want a lasagna. <laugh> about it.
<laugh> if I went to a restaurant I'm like, would you like to order,
would I keep a little more on your lasagna? Yes. Please tell me where to stop
instead of salt bay,
its may cause he spray a on the LA just
I.
Started effort to a biscuit, touch my CU, go on, touch it. Go on. I a biscuit.
God my biscuit.
I have so many questions like listen, oh girl,
I know you shouldn't make fun of people, but this is one I can't,
I can't stop watching it fascinates me. I've never felt so creepy.
Watching a young woman enjoy her life, but it's just, I can't stop watching.
This is like the only form of reality TV that I would tune into every day.
The reality about Tourette though, the relative about Tourette. It's not,
it's not everybody that has a Tourette.
As severe as that Tourette syndrome is a common neurodevelopmental disorder that
begins in childhood or adolescents. It is characterized by multiple movement,
motor ticks and at least one vocal phon tick common ticks are
blinking, coughing throat clearing, sniffing, facial on movements.
And some form more, more extremes include swearing, crazy gestures, et cetera,
et cetera. A whole bunch of people was this video was like, oh man,
that's Tourettes. I thought my dad was just an. <laugh>.
Why don't you use Instagram hug a I don't biscuits.
I the queen. Uh, I don't have an Instagram because,
because frankly,
I kind of feel like when people are asking me for Instagram,
they're actually asking if I have like a portfolio of soft porn, um,
that want to see if there are any sexy picks.
That is 100, hundred percent. That is correct. You're correct.
I'm not gonna lie.
I actually looked up her Instagram before we did this video just to see she has
for that reason. <laugh> I, I did it. Did you? I did.
I wanted to see just how sweet Anita is. Okay. Sorry. She started yelling.
Cut. all this. And I'm like, I think I'm in love. I think I gotta look her up.
Know what I mean? Oh man. She's so right. She's right on the money. Wow.
That's a good point. That's a good point. Cause when I ask a girl for Instagram,
I'm just trying to see if she got cakes. <laugh> can I be?
Cause I got a tooth. Let's go. <laugh> all I got that diabetes.
I can't get enough. You love I'm like baby, call me Craig, David.
Cause can you fill me in all right. Having that.
Instagram and I just don't do that sort of thing. Um,
I don't have anything against people who do,
I'm not gonna shame anyone for that. That's how they enjoy their sexuality.
It's just not for me. And I kind of feel weird when people are asking for that.
It's like, hi, I like your face. Can I see you naked?
It's just such a weird dynamic.
And we all know that that's what dudes are low key asking for when they ask for
you.
Instagram. I really like this person. I like this person. Yeah. I like her too.
Yeah, I know. I just rejected fighter for like five minutes straight,
but genuinely as thought that was a really great response.
And it does raise a really interesting question about Instagram.
Cause I'm not gonna lie to you. I would say 90% of Instagram,
even for casual people. It was just about sexualizing them
for the majority of people. Yeah. There's good people on there.
There's a bunch of, a lot of people on there. That's not for that,
but it's just like, you know, like when you look at internet, you know,
there's a lot of good information on internet,
but for every website of whatever, there's two websites of porn on internet,
you know? Yeah. She raised like a really good point. It's like, you know,
at least with Facebook you can say, you're keeping in touch with people.
You're staying up to date with stuff. <affirmative>, you know,
there's definitely a lot of like upsides for me,
just for like the casual use of Facebook for my family and friends and stuff at
work.
Instagram to me just strikes me like a lot of attention seeking and a lot of
sexualization. It's like, I've heard people say like, yeah,
I'm following a bunch of inspiring women.
And then you'll click on the inspiring women they're following.
And it's just like women in like really tight clothes where that is very like
visible. And I'm just like, okay, again, I'm not criticizing people for it.
I'm not saying it's bad, but I'm like,
it does raise an interesting point point when we're asking somebody for
their in game before being honest,
the only reason we're asking is like to see if that person looks good. Well,
you know, back in the days, the only people that had a portfolio were artists,
visual artists, photographers
tax artist. But you didn't bring that thing with you. You know what I mean?
Now everybody has a fol, right? Everybody access has,
has access to an array of pictures of how they look. If you wanna contact me,
there's a lot of other ways of contacting me in the Instagram.
And there's some you pull sometimes they'll go straight to the Instagram. Yeah.
What's your Instagram. So the opposite text gonna go straight for the Instagram.
It's it's a way to get a lot of information about you. What you look like.
I know for me,
there have been times where like a girl's hit me up online and I look up her
Instagram to see. Cause like, you know,
like one of her profiles only has like her face. I'm just like, but she may not.
So I saw are going through everything else to find out. Yeah.
And just to be like, right. She looks good and I'm not, I'm not the only one.
No, you're part of the problem. I'm kidding.
<laugh> but not really. I did, I did answer cuz I was like, he's kinda right.
<laugh> you're part of the problem. So officer don't shoot and you're like,
you there <laugh> and see that clip. But yeah, you're part of the problem,
which is fine. It's okay. You're not blaming them.
You're just acknowledging the fact that so it's not like you're pointing people.
A VPN is a virtual private network. So privacy protection tool,
which guarantees your online safety.
So when you're surfing the web and you wanna protect your passwords,
your videos, your photos, all your encrypted data,
and you wanna make sure that nobody steals it.
That's where a VPN comes in and keeps all of your stuff safe. Look, guys,
I know times are tough. You're gonna be bored. You're gonna want to do things.
And so there might be TV shows you wanna watch.
And those TV shows might get blocked. Cuz your IP address,
you didn't choose where you were born. You didn't choose. Well,
you kind of chose where you lived. But anyways,
if you want to be able to watch these TV shows,
you shouldn't have to move to do so use a VPN bypass that.
And that's where surf chart comes in now because you're one of our fans.
You know what I'm saying about to hook you up 83% off plus one month for free.
That's a good deal. You paying 17%.
You just paying the taxes or you're not literally, but I'm just saying,
you know, get 17 anyways. It's not that important. Try it out.
They got a 30 day money back guarantee. But if you want access,
all these TV shows,
there's a whole bunch of good stuff that's gonna come out because we know we
gonna be bored during this pandemic. Jump on it. Thank you to surf shark.
We really appreciate their support. I've had women do it to me too. Of course.
Cuz people are like, Abba come. You don't post more yourself.
Cause I'll post videos of me dancing. Right? I'll post pictures of me.
But I won't like do all the like
the reason why I don't do more is cause I know what it's for.
I know it's still like get women to get thirsty and try to raise their desire
levels. And I'm like, I don't think I want to do that. Hmm.
I have friends who literally have an account where never post.
They just follow a bunch of Instagram. Yeah. Well the people on,
on Instagram for different things, there's there are followers, right?
And people that are followed right.
There are people that do not post and really just follow.
And it's really for an entertainment.
They're not here to expose anything or anything. Whatnot. You know what I mean?
It's like the,
you remember how like models and like super models on TV back in the day used to
a lot of people psyche. Yes. I feel like Instagram does that at times 10.
Absolutely. EV because like, because before you at least cognize,
it was just super models and they were the exception. Yep.
Now it's everyday girls who are taking these ridiculous angles to make their,
which doesn't even look like what they look like in real life.
Cause I'll see Instagram models sometimes in real life.
I'm like your picture do, do not. Do you justice? No back.
You know, you do not do justice to your pictures, but bars.
And so it creates this ridiculous standard.
It's worse before like all those super models,
they were super models. It, it was,
you recognize it was something insane. It was yeah.
It was the standard that was not into, it was something that was out there. Yes.
People tried,
but it was really something that was now it's girl next door and the
twerk.
And funny you said that cuz the girl next door is literally doing that on
<laugh>. Yeah. Sometimes I crew to the picture. I'm like
Instagram live <laugh>
yes. Leslie, if you're seeing this, I apologize. Who Leslie. Oh,
that's her Instagram name. Okay side. Didn't give her a real name. No,
of course not. Yeah. Yeah. I wouldn't do. But that,
that you people tweak and TW their pings to look a certain world.
That's anybody guys and girls, guys and girls. It's not just the girls.
It's a guys too. I wouldn't know. Cause I don't follow dudes.
I don't look at no male profiles.
I got one friend who's like in the NFL and that's my homie one who does music.
And if they start posting selfies, I look soft suspect. I'd be like, Hey,
good luck in your life. But it's just ladies. It is the guys too.
I have to admit, I have a bias.
I don't like when a girl posts too much fast selfies. If it's just selfies,
I just delete that. But if it's a guy, I delete it.
And I judge I'm like you got problems. It does make sense though. Why?
Because again,
it's like you recognize that women are judged far more for their looks and their
values based off their looks. Yes. So you judging a man for,
for being that vapid makes sense because you're like, bro,
you're not in terms of like the, the natural selection of the way things work.
You're not even investing in the other stuff. You're just on your looks. Yeah.
Which it seems even more VA it in a weird way. Yeah.
Cause you're not even judged on that. Right.
As much as women are judged on that. I mean,
there's nothing sexual to me that when I meet a girl, she's like,
I don't have an Instagram. And I'm like, who, who is you? <laugh>? Who is you?
Who is you? You don't got no Instagram girl. I can't direct message you.
I gotta talk to you to talk. Wow. I mean, at the end of the day,
I'm a probably just sit on this for a couple days and probably just think about
it. But yeah, that means it's just gonna watch more videos of her.
Yeah. We all know it.
[inaudible]. the queen of the. <laugh> sorry. Sorry. <laugh> sorry. Oh
unfortunately the reality is that regardless of what women do and
how little efforts they put forth, we're always gonna go through the, a
process of sexualizing them. You. Yeah, it is one of the realities of our
world. It's something that I don't know if we can get around. I think we
sexualize each other as genders pretty much all the time. <laugh>
, you know, it's tough, but I do respect her stance. I thought she brought up an interesting point and
uh,  you know, all jokes aside, she should start an Instagram. Uh,
so that's, if any other place you wanna make? No. Any thoughts you want to
have about Tourettes? What are your thoughts about Tourettes? Uh,
my thoughts about Tourettes, uh, Tourettes Tourettes, I've seen, I've seen and
I've worked with people with Tourettes.
Okay. The person I was working with that has Tourettes was milder than this.
Right. Uh, so we spoke about it. So the point is to speak about it and then,
you know, everybody understand what the what's going on and are able to move on.
Right. At some point you get passed through that and you're like,
you understand that what's going on.
And just part of the personality of the person, but yeah, it's a hard, not life.
You know what I mean?
You can't have what I was saying basically is not that that the vast majority of
people are don't have tourists as bad as that. Yeah. No like they have like,
it's mild than that, but yeah, when it goes, when it goes, it goes,
but I'm happy. I'm happy to just see somebody like that.
Be able to find a living, be successful. Uh, despite all that and uh,
speaks highly of, uh, basically character.
So congratulations and uh, yeah, start the Instagram. That's it.
<laugh> sweet. Anita. You ain't got this. Just do your thing. No, start it.
I don't get, I want start it. Don't don't get in the way of me and all her fans.
Go on, start Instagram. Don't do it. Girl. Start Instagram. Don't don't do it.
Start the why you talking me? <laugh>
you didn't say stupid. CU.
You do arts. I do draw. Um, you can check out the discord.
There's a couple of my drawings on the discord,
just an unfinished sketch of my bearded dragon. And um,
Myun no, I didn't draw my CU.
I mean <laugh>
is this the confusing way? You're <laugh> no, if you heard the guy go,
I mean, this man really went well. I mean, you know,
it looked like to me, I mean it thicker than bowl oatmeal.
I said that
whenever I've met girls and they've had like huge Instagram followings and we're
talking, I've never thought it was a good thing.
Didn't think it was necessarily a bad thing,
but it didn't make them more desirable. Mm-hmm <affirmative>,
that's what you're saying. It's just, it's weird. It it's like,
I'm not taking my time to wrap my head around it,
but I remember I really got into Instagram late, like last two years. Yes.
And even then I barely use it.
I got like 40 PO posts in like three years and
I try not to stay and hang out on it at all. I fact,
I post what I have to post for or work and I pretty much get off. Oh.
Sometimes people DM me and I'm like, eh, I'm saying, but other than that,
I'm sorry. What? Yeah, I'm saying let, okay.
Go Gators.
<laugh> you things V she raised a good point.
And so here's what I'm gonna raise to. Oh, okay.
If I'm a woman and I'm on a date and a dude asked me for my Instagram,
should I see that as a bad thing? I think it's a thing
it's not necessarily good. It's not necessarily bad. I you're on a date.
Or you want to ask for a date that could mean that he wants to see more of you
in order to see more of you. And it depends if a lot of parameters,
it's not just necessarily a good thing. It's not necessarily a bad thing.
It's a thing. I mean, it shows interest.
So basically Instagram is like Tinder without the swipes. Yes.
It could be served as that. Definitely. It is being served as that. Yeah.
It's another Tinder. I mean, you know, it's interesting.